all right Brandon I mean is the show
feeling real now that you're at the MTV
Movie and TV Awards no not at all I mean
it's insane I definitely didn't expect
this much craziness around all of this I
mean this is my first yeah this is my
first MTV Movie Awards and it's crazy
the hills almost feels like how is it
not here yet because it's so highly
anticipated are you guys as a cast
feeling the pressure feels like we've
been shooting this for over a year now
so it's like yeah I mean I'm definitely
I definitely wanted to come out as fast
as possible so I can get that first
episode like oh my god thank God it's
just out you know I'm just I don't know
it's the first time people are gonna
meet me really on TV and in a big way so
yeah I'm definitely anticipating what
people are gonna say what people are
gonna think and of course the show's
been gone for ten years so I think more
than anything the fans have been waiting
for it so I just rather get that to them
as fast as possible I mean it's all
about the drama how does it compare to
that first season or first series the
first series you know what I'm guilty
I've never watched one episode of the
original yeah I've never watched one
episode but from what everyone else has
told me there's way more drama than
original I feel like in the original
from what I've seen it was a lot more
like it was the first time anything like
this had been done and people hadn't
really been used to reality TV and what
it is and getting like you know these
producers are in your face and it was a
little more like formulated back then
this is like real real people real drama
real life so not scripted and staged not
at all okay are we gonna see mom and dad
on the show you have to watch but yeah I
think I think I think in the teaser or
something my mom makes in the teaser but
you know yeah I just have to wait and
see there's a lot that went on what can
you tease as being a moment on the show
people are really gonna be talking about
a moment on the show that really for me
it's definitely gonna be you know I
never thought I would go through a
relationship on the show just because
I'm a very private person and ever
wanted any romantic part of my life to
be a public display but so that is kind
of a big moment for me that I'm waiting
to see how you know there's some
relationships that play out for me on
the
show and I kind of want to see how that
looks the original cast members what you
thought they would be like Heidi and
Spencer Heidi and Spencer were exactly
how I thought they would be
Stephanie Pratt was exactly how I
thought she would be I grew up with
Brody so Brody just always been the same
way he's just like a chill guy Spencer
and Stephanie are now well there was
some drama between the two of them yeah
I'm sorry I'm so used to it that's
average no it's insane they can't even
be in the same room together even right
now mmm you see it all play out on the
show 100% all of it
whose side are you on I don't pick sides
you know I don't know we'll figure it
out
[Applause]
[Music]